[Music]
hey it's us again
hopefully this [ __ ] doesn't drop out on
us again yeah i don't know what's up
we'll try not to go on and on too long
because i think the longer we go on the
more
we risk it like [ __ ] dropping out
there isn't a whole lot to say about
this one anyway
yeah this is okay so this was a movie
that i saw i kept coming up on like you
know
good movies on hulu good movies on uh
you know best
movies of last year or whatever so i
finally got around to watching this one
this is called sputnik
uh this is a russian i guess i'd call it
a sci-fi thriller
or type thing i mean it does have some
gore in it
um but it is kind of more of a thriller
type of story
um so this supposedly this was like the
first the guy that directed it was named
igor
abramenko and this is actually his
feature length
debut i think he made some short films
prior to that um
this was actually supposed to premiere
at tribeca
the film festival last april but of
course you know tribeca got postponed
and they didn't show any of the movies
so finally they just released it to vod
uh in mid-april of 2020 and uh
it seemed like it did really really well
in russia like i think it had
over a million or two million downloads
or something like that like within a
week of it being out
and it actually was released in some
theaters like a limited release and made
like a decent amount of money there too
so it did seem like this was pretty
successful it seems like it's mostly got
some uh
some good reviews as well yeah here's
the setup
russian cosmonauts back in the damn uh
ussr appearance
in 1983. it was 83 it was 83 yeah so
it's before the collapse
and um so we're talking about good ol
good old russia the soviet union russia
they're up in space in a space capsule
and it gets attacked by something
extraterrestrial one dude
makes it back and he's got this damn
alien parasite in him
and well i guess it's not really a
parasite it's more like a symbiote
yeah it comes out of him and does stuff
and goes back in and they're kind of
joined
and jenny kind of picked up on it i
didn't i didn't realize
i didn't realize it until she said it it
was kind of like venom
the movie venom yeah but like not funny
or superhero
it's more like a realistic serious it
was like a merger of prometheus
and alien one
venom i liked it it was a good movie
production values were good acting was
really good
sets and everything but it felt like you
were back in the old in the soviet union
uh special effects were good the alien
looked pretty good
i mean considering this movie i think
only cost like two million dollars to
make
two and a half million it's [ __ ] free
yeah yeah i mean it looks really really
good i thought that i thought the alien
the symbiote looked really really good
it had
it had a really good score too i loved
the score
you could tell it was like prometheus
inspired score
so i don't want to call it i want to say
it's like a russian
rip-off of prometheus because it isn't
but you could tell some things were kind
of inspired from prometheus well they
took a lot of inspiration from some
others some people have compared it to
the movie life
uh with jake gyllenhaal and ryan
reynolds which i haven't seen
but a lot of i've heard a lot of other
reviewers comparing it to that so maybe
it's similar i don't know
it's just the whole si the whole symbian
thing um
just that that triggered for me i was
like oh kind of like venom
but not funny or like super heroey you
know what i'm saying
yeah it reminded me a little bit too of
this is going to be kind of out there
but because i'm like a mystery science
theater fan
it kind of reminded me too of this movie
from the 50s i think it was a roger
corman movie called knight of the blood
beast
where an astronaut comes back to earth
in a capsule
and they think he's dead at first and
they bring him back to the lab and
they're trying to figure out what killed
him
and then he wakes back up and they're
all very surprised as you would be
and then they find out that his stomach
is filled with um alien babies yeah
that look like little party shrimp yeah
yep and uh and they're
and the aliens are essentially like
animating him so
you can tell like the mst guys had a
[ __ ] field day with that because of
you know
man pregnancy that's like always funny
so it was like they had so many they had
such a good time with that but it kind
of reminded me a little bit of that too
but the interesting thing about this one
i liked that there was a
kind of this this sort of like emotional
core to it like i said it's more a
thriller or a drama
with horror and sci-fi elements i guess
um
because what your main character
constantine is the name of the cosmonaut
that comes back
with the the symbiote
but also the other main character is
this doctor
um named tatyana and she is kind of like
she's drawn into this story because
she's kind of like a i guess she's a
psychiatrist
but she's kind of well known for being
like not playing by the rules and all
this other kind of stuff so this secret
military operation about the cosmonaut
because obviously they don't want
anybody to know about this
um you know so so they kind of get wind
of her and they bring her into it and
say
because at first when he comes you know
when he comes back
they tell her that well you know he came
back and we're not really sure
something's wrong with him but we don't
know entirely what it is and we want you
to
have some insight into what's going on
with him
but you find out later that they are not
really being completely honest with her
um and everyone's kind of lying to each
other i want to spoil too much about it
because
like i said this is just from 2020 and i
feel like a lot of people because i
think even mango um
said that they wanted to see it it was
like on their watch list um
so i don't really want to spoil too much
about it but
this was a really good it gave me a
little bit
it was almost kind of like the vast of
night kind it had that same kind of tone
to it i feel like
maybe not as funny this was this is very
very serious and it's very very
um you know relationship based between
like everybody kind of
lying to everybody and all this other
kind of stuff and all this weird [ __ ]
about the
the alien i really like the alien design
i think the alien looks really good like
it's reminiscent of some other
like little monster aliens but it had
its own
kind of thing going on it looks kind of
like a
kind of like a cross between a
salamander and a damn
jellyfish like cobra like it's kind yeah
like it's kind of cute but
also kind of creepy at the same time
yeah it grows too i think it kind of
matures as it went along because
yeah because it seemed like it got
different like the long started off with
just a tail like a
like like a fluke worm yeah but then
over then
over time with like long arms yeah like
over time it developed legs in the back
of it though
and a tail it got stronger as it went
i don't think it was fully formed into
what it was gonna be
like i said i don't want to call it an
alien or prometheus knockoff there was
kind of like a
i could i could tell there was some
influence there some spiritual influence
especially
especially in the score the score was
really good yeah
i didn't realize that this was such a
low-budget movie i didn't realize that
either i would never have imagined that
it would only cost like
i was like man i wish it doesn't look
like it because i was at first i was
kind of like i wish you wouldn't have
gone in that direction i wish it would
have been something like finding a fun
crashed alien ship yeah because you were
saying that earlier in russia it would
have been a little bit better you know
what i mean
but i didn't realize that there are
probably budgetary restrictions
you know yeah yeah but uh it was pretty
good
i have a i'm kind of skeptical of
russian stuff you know
me growing up in the cold war and
knowing the soviet union
i know their products i mean they had
i've owned a lot of [ __ ]
russian style and east eastern bloc
firearms you know kalashnikovs and
you know makarovs and tokarevs they make
good stuff
but when they were doing [ __ ] in my time
when they were doing [ __ ] that was high
tech or fashion or
uh you know entertainment like consumer
goods it always had an
element of rip-off in it for instance
like
i can remember the the soviets at the
end before they collapsed they came out
with nintendo with the super nintendo
and it was
a super nintendo in it but it was a
it was a ripoff something that they got
from like an unlicensed
copy they put it in a different console
and then they took all the writ the
games and they tweaked them
changed them just a little bit like just
crazy [ __ ] like
they would take mario and turn him into
a duck
and then when he died there'd be like a
big skull coming
music was all [ __ ] up like it was
running backwards it was like a cheap
knockoff of what we had
and whatever kind of clothes towards the
edw that we were kind of
went wearing they would make like a
cheap knock off of that so
some of the movies that i've seen that
came from
russia you could tell they were kind of
it was like a cheap knockoff of
something that they wanted like let's do
a cheap knockoff
what wasn't as bad as like turkish
superman i mean wasn't that bad turkish
ripoffs
are just a whole genre like that but of
their own and a lot of them are
delightful
yeah but recently you know they had some
good original con
good original ones like was i saw a
russian superhero movie about the guy
who had the old russian car
remember that the car oh yeah yeah yeah
that was a good one i don't remember
what that was called
i mean there have been some really good
russian movies what about solaris that
was yes
yeah that was okay this one was i think
this one might have been better than
solaris
really i don't know if i could i don't
know i wouldn't get that i kind of like
this one
which one was solaris which what that
what did that have in it
[ __ ] man i can't even remember they
weren't they going toward the sun it was
like a sunship or something like that
they did a remake of it i don't think i
saw that one
yeah i don't remember you've seen it i
think we have it somewhere i think i
think we have it but
i think one of our peeps sent it to us
i've seen it a long time ago i saw the
remake as well
but it was a long time ago but um so
this is it's good this this movie can
pretty much stand on its own
yeah i wish they hadn't had done it
in the russian military base and under
captivity had been better
if you'd included some of the alien like
technology see where it came from what
was it you know that kind of
or at least teased us a little bit more
this was almost it was like organic
sci-fi because like i said it was more
about
it was more about the relationship of
the doctor
and the cosmonaut and
the [ __ ] that was happening with this
essentially like you said it was
it wasn't a parasite exactly because it
was a symbiotic relationship
and it was almost kind of like the
longer it was in there like they had a
thing where
they even had all these because i guess
it had been a while like since it came
back
since he came back in the uh capsule and
it had they had like all these little uh
you know drawings and stuff
and it's like you know in during the day
like the little symbiont he can like
squish down to like a really small so he
just kind of lives in his esophagus
and uh and his stomach but then at night
he comes out
and um you know and he seemed and it
seemed like the longer the symbiote was
in there
um they were getting more and more
entwined
you know what i mean so because it
seemed like
the sembian was getting fed
um and like i said i don't really want
to spoil what
what it was eating but you'll find
because you'll find out
or what it fed on because that was i
liked that aspect of it
um but essentially the cosmonaut
constantine would have died
if that symbiont hadn't crawled into his
body and taken over
so it was kind of like you know they
were having that kind of relationship
he would like they would die without
each other now when they um
when they first summoned uh the doctor
like tatiana
the the military brass were kind of
telling her well we want to figure out
how to separate them because constantine
is a hero and we don't want this thing
in there
we want to figure out what this thing is
and all this other stuff but like i said
as the movie goes on you find out that
pretty much nobody at the base has been
honest with her about
what the endgame of the experiments are
about what they want her to do about all
this other kind of stuff because you
just kind of find out each thing
like that they have not been honest with
her about and she's pretty sharp so she
like figures it out
yeah so you know donuts don't expect
like uh
sci-fi horror like alien one
or sci-fi action like alien too it
wasn't like that
yeah it's got like a little it's got a
few like monster movie
alien monster movie type of scenes
there's a couple scenes like that
where you know where the [ __ ] um
you know where the alien kind of goes
crazy and like you know chews people up
and stuff
but a lot of it is more it's almost like
a like a mystery story kind of
it's almost more like a mixture like
you're just unraveling like what's
really going on like behind the scenes
it's kind of more like that
and it's kind of more like about the
characters and about their relationship
with one another and what's happening
like a psychotherapy thriller or
something yeah like with just
with some sci-fi now it does have some
gore in it because
um you know the alien does like eat
people's heads off and whatnot
um so there is like a couple of scenes
that are like there was one scene with
like that one dude's head that i was
kind of like way too gross but you know
um but it's you know it's not like an
over-the-top like
monster movie rampage or anything like
that it's much more
character-based drama-based mystery
based
with just you know aspects of like
gore and stuff like that like sprinkled
throughout it but
i don't know like i said it seemed like
it's been getting like really good
reviews and a lot of people really seem
to like it i thought it was like a you
know a really good movie
yes it does um you know take ideas from
other sci-fi movies but
i mean kind of every sci-fi movie takes
ideas from other sci-fi movies i didn't
know it was a low-budget movie
yeah so now that i know it's a
low-budget movie then yeah i respect it
a lot more
i can't believe it it doesn't look
low-budget it really doesn't yeah i mean
i never would have thought that it only
cost like 10 million bucks a month yeah
look expensive
i thought so too yeah yeah but um
yeah it's definitely worth watching i
don't know um it's on hulu
in the u.s that's where we watched it um
so i don't know it might
i'm sure it's probably other places like
maybe you can rent it on youtube
or amazon prime or whatever but um if
you have hulu then you should watch it
on there i wish there would have been a
little bit more mystery about where the
thing had come from and what kind of
technology it had what was it doing here
but they didn't even tease us with any
of that i mean it basically
that's the thing that was missing
because at the very beginning
you see the two cosmonauts constantine
and the other guy that didn't uh really
come back so good
um you see the two of them in the
capsule and they're coming back
and then they're just they just hear
something just on the outside of the
capsule and you don't really see it you
just kind of see a shadow like go across
the window or whatever
and then they're just like what the [ __ ]
and then there's kind of like noise on
the outside
so you're just led to believe that this
creature
is just kind of living in space
someplace or it came from somewhere and
it's
it had it was looking for a host it had
a ridley scott
feel to it yeah and
but unlike with ridley scott would have
teased us with some [ __ ]
yeah and left some stuff hanging and
left a mystery a few mysteries like wait
hold on what was that where'd he go what
was that what'd that do
why was that there well i got to see
more of that what happened to it where
to go
yeah so that's what scott would have
done scott would have teased you with a
bigger picture
and or teased you with a bigger picture
or a wrap-around story that you don't
know about
and that was kind of lacking in this
movie i wish it would have would have
done that
yeah okay yeah i'm talking about yeah
teased us with a bigger picture
of like okay it's here was it here on
purpose
are there more of them are there more of
them yeah was that an accident
was it in a ship it never clear yeah
because it seemed like it was just kind
of in space like
it was just like a creature that lives
right did the russians know this was
coming did the americans know anything
about it what happened there
should have been a little bit of a
bigger mystery around it
i almost felt like i don't know if i
want to go this far but i almost kind of
felt like this
like the symbiote was almost kind of
like could be seen as kind of like a
metaphor for that dude's
like dark side kind of like so like
venomous like that so that that's kind
of why it reminded me of that i mean
obviously he was very
the monster was like real and it crawled
out of him and like did [ __ ]
but um you what have
they done what i said and had a wrap
around it would set up a sequel a lot
better because you'd like because you
would not
because it would it would have questions
laying out there that you'd wanted
answered
but i really didn't feel like i had any
questions after the movie was over and
that's where the movie it was very
self-contained yeah that's
i think where the movie failed didn't
set up its own sequel
yeah but i guess you know not every
movie has to do that some people just
like to make a movie and then make a
difference
i'm telling you there's gonna be guys
that like this movie you're going to
want to see well what happened next
yeah i do most of the most of the
reviews i watched of it like
most were very very positive yeah like
most people actually really like now
what
you know so like i said it's not like uh
you know it's not a super like action
thriller or anything like that it's kind
of a slow burn i guess it's more like a
drama or thriller type of thing
with sci-fi elements now one thing that
i've seen
a lot of people got confused about i
think i was confused about this
at the end too but i figured it out
later
some people have wondered about the end
part where tatiana
goes to the orphanage to adopt the kid
and then there's a scene where the kid
is like i'm not a little boy i'm a
little girl and everybody's like what
like he had a son the whole time
except it was a girl no that's not what
that was that little girl was that was a
flashback that was actually her
tatiana okay and they were showing that
she had grown up as an orphan
that was why she related so much to
constantine and his son and that whole
thing
that's why they were showing that that
so the kid that they were showing was
the whole time was not him it wasn't
leosha
it was her okay i got you because i i
just saw a bunch of
other reviews of it and people were like
what the [ __ ] the boy is a girl now what
the hell happened
so like people were confused so
i was like yeah what was that what was
about that because i was just kind of
like huh
but then you know i figured it out like
after they'll probably make a sequel
they you know they may this this
actually was uh quite successful
particularly for uh you know a russian
film and like i said i didn't realize
until i looked it up that it
that it was that inexpensive to make
because i would never have imagined that
it was that inaudible
yeah the acting was very good yeah you
know we saw it in russian with subtitles
but you could tell the acting was good
and it had a fantastic score
and visually your set up man i really
did love good filters
good good visual tone told the story in
a coherent
coherence it was just so so easy it was
good like it had this gray green kind of
look and then every now and then like
you get this bright red
yeah kind of [ __ ] it was yeah it was
really really good but yeah so
if you're into kind of like more a
little bit more cerebral
sci-fi i guess you call it check it out
mango said it's on uh in the uk he said
it's on netflix and uh
on netflix in the uk i don't think it's
on netflix here but
um it is on hulu here and i'm sure it's
on probably other
streaming services as well um is there
anything else you would
like to discuss fourth drawer down said
that the uh
that the soviet nintendo was called
nintendosky
i know i was like these nests wanted me
to see
i went to that oh hey people i went i
went to that appointment today got my
blood work done
see i thought you'd want to bring that
up paid my [ __ ] consultation and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and uh that that doctor that
he's an endocrinologist he also works at
a va he goes i know your eye doctor and
i was like yeah yeah they're talking to
you guys
i'm gonna get you jacked i'm gonna get
you jacked
wait for your blood work to come back so
i can see the doses
you know he had all kinds of [ __ ] he
goes you know i got some all kinds i got
some
i got some peptides i got stuff over
here i got some stuff over here
you know i got a [ __ ] physical
performance program too and i'm looking
at the prices i could say
like on a menu it was more expensive i
thought it was going to be
it was about twice it's like 200 bucks a
month just for the [ __ ] just for the
trt
but they do blood workers automatically
which is good a lot better support team
they seem like they really keep track of
your [ __ ] for that price they're
throwing in quarterly blood work and
blood analysis and try to keep your
levels good and [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] i saw what else was on
the menu there was just a
lot of uh you know it wasn't just
[ __ ] you know like
they got to be careful [ __ ] you know
what they call certain things but i
i understood but the message was clear
there was some um
there was some um high performance
options
on there high performance yeah there are
some high performance options on there
but uh we'll see you guys once you start
working together in all your dosages we
can tweak some things here and then
and then we'll see how you feel after
about three or four months and then you
know i got some other stuff you might
want to check out you know and he says
you're in good condition
he says you're not you haven't been
abused or anything by a bunch of
anabolics in the past the same thing i
told you
and he goes you're pretty much free to
do whatever you want i mean what do you
got
25 years man [ __ ] cruise out of here
yeah
he goes you know the risks man [ __ ]
you know at this point you know
[ __ ] what's it gonna cost you a month
or two come on
man freaking i'd give up a month of life
to either give a month of life on
average to have the next 25 years just
zooming well i mean
and the thing about it is that if you're
giving up a month it's the last month
yeah exactly it's the you wouldn't know
the difference and the quality of all
the time would be better and here's
another thing is that's just statistical
[ __ ]
yeah that's not what actually could
happen i did the research and actually
having all that [ __ ] balanced ends up
preventing a lot of bad
problems like preventing diabetes or
[ __ ]
cardiovascular disease the the the
evidence they've been [ __ ] with it
for decades 30 years they know what it
does
and the evidence seems to suggest that
now it prevents
a lot of other age-related problems
because those problems are coming from
those hormonal imbalances
of the program death you're programmed
to die
yeah and it's not fast it takes well you
know 25 or 30 years is
fast from the point of view of evolution
well it's just tripping the switch okay
you're done
get out and get out that's what it's
telling you
he laughed at me because because he
doesn't have a phone so
all right so if anybody has to call them
they have to call me you know yeah [ __ ]
them phones
and um so so the guy called this morning
and i had to put the number in there
and he laughed at me because i called it
man clinic
but yeah they had [ __ ] for females
though too man [ __ ] put her on that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] get you zooming out of here i
don't know man i don't
i don't want to spend 200 a month come
on i can't afford that [ __ ]
might prevent other problems that cost
even more later
yeah sure like maintenance maintenance
costs
maybe maybe we can get you a better deal
maybe get a family package
[Laughter]
get a family yeah look man i'm being
honest i'm being honest
what what what the [ __ ] you know i
got i got friends that are doctors you
know what i mean
[ __ ] they're they're glorified drug
dealers really
you know you know what you want [ __ ]
yeah i can't even give it to you
in mexico in mexico you wouldn't even
need a [ __ ] prescription you just buy
the [ __ ] over the counter
yeah but but i want that but i want that
regular blood work though
i think that's wise i mean just
it'd be good to catch um what garcia
sent us some money oh
oh thanks thank you victor that's jade
man clinic [ __ ]
man yeah well you know [ __ ] standing
up hard as a rock
i mean what the hell else am i going to
call it the main clinic i just thought
it was well i was going to call it
something else but i decided not to
but like a hormone clinic hormone
replacement therapy
i just thought yeah it's like you just
you went on the online yesterday to like
make the appointment
yeah two miles away and then yeah and
then they called this morning and said
hey come down here at 9 45 this morning
and we'll get you
set up so you have to go back thursday i
think right like when your blood work
comes yeah cool
it's cool cool dudes we'll see how it
goes yeah
so [ __ ] man look you had cute women in
there they had a woman in there getting
[ __ ]
getting hormones replaced yeah she's
about your age yeah
she's fat though she's like i'm trying
to lose weight
yeah like and then the other guy was in
there he's like man i lost 20 pounds
yeah yeah because some of that some of
those regimens were
they were basically weight loss there's
a hormone replacements that [ __ ]
encourage
hormones that encourage weight loss so
it could be that like
when you go on the regimen you're just
going to be rampaging all over this [ __ ]
all over this screen right here well
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
whenever everything's set right your
metabolism is very forgiving about what
you're eating
yeah and so and your metabolism kind of
goes back to its normal state of just
running
not trying to [ __ ] just hang on for
dear life just run it normally
no we need all that fat yeah we need all
that [ __ ] let's keep it yeah don't die
so um they go on a diet
but now all of a sudden they're able to
lose all kinds of weight because their
their metabolism is working a lot better
than
like a teenager yeah it's basically
human and it's not
it's not you know what i mean they don't
stay on that
regimen it might be a six month thing
yeah or a year thing and then they come
back home put them on something else
but you know man these dudes know all
about that [ __ ] he's intricate
yeah andrew that's a celebrity [ __ ] man
i told him you need some virgin blood
you know yeah well
probably yeah all right so uh
we have anything else you would like to
add that's it all right
yeah so watch sputnik take man drugs
yeah it's all good
[Laughter]
all right we'll have to find a movie to
watch tonight that we can talk about
tomorrow
um i i have no idea but i'll i'll search
through and find something that sounds
good that i'm in the mood for
and uh you know victor says gotta eat
some baby batter ew
oh my god all right so thanks everybody
for
dropping by and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow
same time same place so bye